thousands of people gather in different
parts of yangon
but all with the same demands they want
leader aung san tsuchi and others
detained since the coup to be released
and for the military to hand back
need you control protect the country in
the good way
to protect the democratic also democracy
that all
we want
in mandalay students honored a young
protester shot by police during a
protest in napidor last week
she remains in critical condition this
is the ninth consecutive day of mass
demonstrations across
the country some protesters held signs
that read
stop kidnapping people at night a
reference to nighttime raids by police
when activists and protesters are
arrested
in some neighborhoods people have banned
it together to form watch groups
to warn each other when security forces
are coming
but also to look out for criminals in
this neighborhood of yangon
residents say they caught four men they
suspect of planning to carry out
an attack they believe the men are
recently released prisoners
freed under an amnesty announced by the
military on friday
we think the military intends to cause
violence with these ex-criminals
by getting them to infiltrate the
peaceful protests
then the military will have a reason to
extend their power to crack down on
violence
his claim cannot be independently
verified
a group that advocates for political
prisoners in myanmar
has expressed concerns that the pardon
for more than 23 000 prisoners
is to clear space for the detention of
detainees during the current
protests the military is also bringing
back repressive laws
used by the previous military junta
including a requirement for people to
report
overnight guests in their homes to
authorities around
360 people detained since the coup are
still being held
but neither the risk of arrest nor fear
of a crackdown
are enough to deter these protesters
from taking to the streets
florence louis al jazeera